do we finally know where the last two
remaining road ponoglyphs are that the
striats still need to find so they can
finally reach love tape well at the very
least we have just gotten a few major
clues and a bunch of new information
dropped on our heads there are three
likely locations for it albath an island
called vida and beehive island
blackbeard's base of operation and as i
will explain to you i personally believe
that elbaf and shanks are the most
likely candidates here now you might be
like manu where is this information
coming from there is no one piece
chapter this week well wrong kind of
even though the one piece manga is on a
four week break at the moment each year
order the author of one piece has
decided to release a series of four mini
booklets as a small gift to readers in
every release of shonen jump in the
meantime instead this little series is
titled the road to love tale and
documents or senses preparation for the
final saga of one piece these booklets
contain a lot of character sketches and
recaps of things we already know however
there are also some very chunky nuggets
of fresh information and reveals to be
found there as well and so the very
first volume that's out now is focused
very heavily on roger and how he became
pirate king dedicating a whole page to
the mysterious poneglyphs and by far the
biggest thing in all of this i think is
that oda sensei discusses the locations
of the four road pony cliffs here we
have of course already the two that the
straw hats have in their possession the
one from zou and one from big mom that
broke heroically made a successful
rubbing off similar to how roger got his
hands on it actually the third road
poneglyph roger found in wano itself and
the last one was located in fishman
island where it stood right next to
joyboy's apology ladder to the mermaid
princess now funnily enough we didn't
actually know for a fact whether the
third road poneglyph was still in one or
not all we've seen so far are two of the
30 plus real pony glyphs that detail the
history of the void century however this
booklet now tells us for sure that
kaido's rule over a closed border wano
has kept anyone else from getting their
hands on his road poneglyph which is a
huge deal in a number of ways because i
think it basically the first time we
officially get confirmed that it's still
waiting right here in wano for the straw
hats to be found and as we all know that
basically means that the straw hats very
very soon will get their hands on it it
also means we still have another story
threat that needs to happen in wano
which makes me happy because i really
didn't want to leave the country as
quickly as the last few chapters made it
originally seen however it also means
that other people probably know that the
poneglyph is here and might now come for
the very same road podoglyph i'm
thinking of course blackbeard and for
some reason now also buggy luffy's two
main rivals to becoming pirate king
because blackbeard surely would have
been fully aware of kaido sitting on top
of that particular red stone it might
also be the reason or at least one of
the reasons why momo decided to leave
wanos borders closed for now at least
until luffy reaches love tale telling
sunisha basically well thanks for
dropping by but you know could you come
back at a more convenient time please
and so the fact that a road poneglyph is
located in wano also adds a lot more
weight to the reveal that odin's father
and momonosuke's grandfather kozuki
sukiyaki former shogun of wano and heir
to the kazuki clan is still alive i
don't know how but i somehow totally
overlooked that in the last chapter but
he was obviously the one who taught odin
how to read and write the language of
the ancient kingdom in other words oda
just snuck another character back into
the story that can potentially lead the
way to the final islands this is huge
sukiyaki might be the lottery ticket
someone like blackbeard has been waiting
for to make his way to love tale as well
should he not be able to get his hands
on robin because him and robin are
pretty much the only two confirmed
people alive who can't read this
language and decipher the pony glyphs
and should blackbeard make his way to
wano to get it and find out who sukiyaki
really is
that would be a true advantage falling
into his hands but i mean as if this
wasn't enough already oda sensei also
decided to tease us with the location of
the last remaining lost road poneglyph
that used to be on fishman islands and
he gives us three possible locations
here elbaf beehive island itself and
vida now you might be asking what a
usopp is a vita well it's actually an
island that was named in the story
before by nami very early on in the
story as she's reading nolan's journal
in other words vida is an island that
was visited by noland 400 years ago and
was described as a very lively and happy
place well since then we found out that
this small town expanded into a
full-blown country but it no longer is
the happy place you can easily live and
smile at instead it was ruled by a
tyrannical government probably
associated with the world nobles and so
after the breakout of a major rebellion
two years ago it was finally freed by
the revolutionary army now sensei of
course does mention here as well that
there are other possibilities for the
location as he should if we're being
honest but he still chose to focus on
these three specifically and i think it
makes sense because all three of these
islands seem to have ties to powerful
people who might have gotten their hands
on the last rode pony glyph veena is
connected to the revolutionaries and
dragon who clearly know quite a lot
about the true history which was why
robin in particular got sent to them by
kuma in the first place so maybe vita is
now the island that the revolutionaries
have moved their scent of operation to
after they got raided by blackbeard's
crew on their previous base and who
knows maybe blackbeard came for them
exactly because he knew that they had a
road poneglyph which of course already
brings us to beehive island it used to
be the base for rox diesel back who by
the way also has a whole page dedicated
to him in this booklet that details his
connections to blackbeard who also named
his ship the zebek now this place is
blackbeard's home and since blackbit is
also aiming to become pirate king it
would really not be too far-fetched to
think that he already has gotten his
hands on a pony glyph there as well
though i would say it's not quite as
likely as the last one because lastly
there is elbaf not only has elba been
hinted at over and over and over again
to be the next island the straw heads
will travel to after wano as i've
discussed in previous videos i mean you
have usop's relationship to the giants
big mom's relationship to the giants the
introduction of loki and so on but it
also seems like elbaf has very strong
ties to another yonko shanks as i've
explained in his character analysis
shanks has a very strong viking theme
going on there's of course a ship that
has the exact same style as dory and
braggi's but shanks is also inspired by
the nordic god tier who has also lost an
arm to a beast and enough of other
parallels as well we also know that the
yonko including shanks holds territory
in the new world again something that is
discussed in detail in the road to love
tale here territorial dispute in the new
world between the yonko and ko and so i
have always been a very strong supporter
of the idea
that elbaf is part of shanks's territory
his home turf in the new world if you
like a man with a bounty of over 4
billion berries i have 61 million
berries 100 for each subscriber ouch but
we're not trying to beat shanks we're
trying to beat a treble who has 99
million for the magical 100 million
berries in other words one million
subscribers and so not only can you help
me make this dream come true by
subscribing but you also get freshly
harvested one-piece content every single
week in return and so i think it would
truly make sense for the man who's
making sure to carry on raj's will as a
yonko to grab the most easily accessible
road poneglyph from fishman island and
put it on elbaf to protect it only for
the right person to see the man roger
was waiting for in other words luffy
shanks definitely knew about this road
poneglyph there because he traveled to
fishman island with roger albath is a
true fortress of an island just like one
all filled with some of the most
fearsome and powerful warriors in the
entire world so really what better place
to have the final road poneglyph hidden
then the next location that the striats
are probably heading to a place where
luffy can finally meet changs a place
where he can earn the right to the last
redstone and prove his worth as a yonko
and also a place where finally shanks
and blackbeard might face each other
once again as blackbeard would surely
come for that very same poneglyph as
well and if you really want to know what
has been foreshadowed about elbaf and
how the arc might play out in the end
and why shanks has such strong ties to
nordic mythology you should really not
miss out on these two videos right here